THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW TO REACT IS
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
PRESIDENT BRANDON JUDD.
BRANDON, THANKS FOR TAKING TIME
ON SATURDAY.
YOU JUST HEARD RICH’S REPORT
THERE AND THE RGV, AGENTS TELL
ME THEY HAD ABOUT 1640
APPREHENSIONS IN THE LAST 24
HOURS.
IT’S REALLY GETTING PRETTY MUCH
TO THE POINT THEY HAVEN’T EVEN
SEEN IN THEIR 20-YEAR CAREER.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION?
WHAT DO WE DO?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT’S
HAPPENING THERE ON THE GROUND AT
THE BOARER?
>> THE SOLUTION IS -- BORDER.
THE SOLUTION IS VERY SIMPLE.
WE HAVE TO LOOK TOWARDS THE
FUTURE.
I MEAN, AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE
TO RELEASE PEOPLE INTO THE
UNITED STATES AFTER THEY VIOLATE
OUR LAWS WITH NO CONSEQUENCES,
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
COME.
THAT’S THE SIMPLE FACT.
OBVIOUSLY, PEOPLE ARE COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE THIS IS THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
WE DO HAVE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
THE BIGGEST OPEN ARMS, WE WANT
TO ACCEPT PEOPLE INTO THIS
COUNTRY, BUT WE WANT TO DO IT
LEGALLY, NOT ILLEGALLY.
AND THAT’S THE PROBLEM, IS BOTH
THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT WANT TO
CONTINUE TO POLITICIZE THIS
ISSUE, BUT THE LEFT WANTS TO
EXCUSE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY WANT TO EXCUSE THE CARTELS
ABUSING THESE CHILDREN, TAKING
THESE CHILDREN AND SEXUALLY
ABUSING THEM, PHYSICALLY ABUSING
THEM, MENTALLY ABUSING THEM.
YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO EXCUSE
THIS, AND THEY CONTINUE BY
POLICY, THEY CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE THIS SITUATION.
IT’S GAINING CARTELS GROUND, AND
IT’S MAKING THEM BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR OFF OF HUMAN
MISERY.
GRIFF: BRANDON, YOU MENTIONED
THE RELEASE OF THE MIGRANTS, AND
WE’VE COVERED THAT QUITE
EXTENSIVELY, BUT YOU SENT ME
THIS MORNING A STORY OF WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN ARIZONA WHERE THE
TEXAS DPS, DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY, MADE A TRAFFIC STOP AND
RELEASED SOME MIGRANTS.
EXPLAIN.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS JUST A GOOD WITH EXAMPLE
OF HOW OVERWHELMED THE UNITED
STATES BORDER PATROL IS RIGHT
NOW.
TEXAS DPS MADE A STOP.
THERE WERE 17 PEOPLE IN A
VEHICLE.
I MEAN, THAT’S DANGEROUS RIGHT
THERE.
I MEAN, WE JUST SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN EL SEVEN TROH,
CALIFORNIA -- EL CENTRO,
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THESE SMUGGLERS, THEY DON’T
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE.
BUT WHEN THEY OVERWHELM THE
SYSTEM, THEN WE DON’T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO GO UP AND TAKE
THESE PEOPLE INTO CUSTODY.
ARIZONA DPS HAD TO RELEASE THESE
17 INDIVIDUALS.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO THEY ARE, WE
DON’T KNOW WHAT COUNTRIES
THEY’RE FROM, WE DON’T KNOW WHAT
THEIR INTENTIONS ARE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND THAT’S
EXTREMELY SCARY.
AND WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH
THE 61,000 PEOPLE THAT WERE ABLE
TO EVADE APPREHENSIONS IN THE
MONTHS OF FEBRUARY AND MARCH,
THAT IS A SCARY SITUATION FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
GRIFF: WE’VE JUST GOT ABOUT 30
SECONDS, BUT I DO WANT TO ASK
YOU, VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS HAS
SAID SHE WILL TRAVEL SOON TO
GUATEMALA AND ALSO TO MEXICO,
BUT NOT TO THE U.S. BORDER.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> BECAUSE IF SHE GOES TO THE
U.S. BORDER, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
EXPECT HER TO FIX THE PROBLEM,
SO SHE AVOIDS IT.
THAT IS, THAT’S DISGUSTING
BECAUSE THAT’S PUTTING POLITICS
AHEAD OF WHAT’S BEST FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT ARE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
GRIFF: BRANDON JUDD, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND WEIGHING IN.